getting a steam deck just got a whole
lot easier and hideo Kojima is teasing
his next project again
nothing feels quite like good news on a
Friday for those of you still looking to
order a steam deck you're in luck
because you no longer have to make a
reservation or wait in a virtual line to
buy one instead you can just buy it on
demand you know like everything else you
purchase in your life except A PS5 those
are a little harder to get valve has
also unveiled the device's promise
docking station which costs 89 and ships
in one to two weeks this premium
accessory includes not only HDMI
DisplayPort and three USB 3.1 connectors
but also an ethernet port in the
announcement tweet valve also noted a
few nice features that were added in a
recent steam deck update these include
expanded docking station options
simplified Japanese Chinese and Korean
keyboards better trackpad typing and
improved stability in offline mode it
also includes several Advanced control
commands including remapping certain
commands when holding a button as well
as nested menus for more complicated PC
games but even though the weight for
More Steam decks is over the wait for
the next hideo Kojima game is still
going strong however it seems you won't
have to wait much longer as his Studio
Kojima Productions begins to pull back
the curtain on its next project
revealing that the actress L Fanning
will appear in it the first teaser for
this mysterious game was revealed during
the Tokyo game show last month this
teaser was revealed as a part of pax
Australia which is going on now
additional teasers are coming and if
they follow this same pattern a major
gaming event might again be the host if
that's the case the next big gaming
event this year is Gamescom Asia at the
end of October after that kojima's pal
Jeff Keeley is hosting the game awards
in December as for what the new game is
that's anyone's guess people have
commented that the teaser are showing
Fanning's face contains the type of
strands that were depicted in death
stranding art perhaps then Kojima is
teasing the heavily rumored death
stranding too but death stranding too if
it's real is so far away if you want
something to sink your teeth into or I
guess your fingernails into because it's
a steering wheel it's a racing game
Forza Horizon 5 has a big update the
Horizon 10-year anniversary update comes
with a New Horizon origin story and the
midnight battles mode that lets players
collect rare cars by winning races The
Horizon Origins event is a new narrative
experience that spans five chapters and
takes players back in time to relive
iconic game moments from across the
series players who complete all five
chapters will get the 2013 Dodge SRT
Viper GTS anniversary edition this is a
special version of the original Forza
Horizon cover car the free anniversary
update Launches on October 11th kicking
off a four week celebration and the
games are on Game Pass so if you have
that you have no excuse not to try them
out and you know what that's your
homework for the weekend I know I know
you finally got into a match of
OverWatch 2 and that's all you want to
do for the rest of the weekend but too
bad racing racing only all right I'll
see you Tuesday